today's topic number rose now if you're
unaware none Rose is a fighter and Muay
Thai fighter from Thailand a transgender
athlete and she is competing over 300
fights won over a hundred and fifty of
them as well as thirty by knockout what
is particularly known rose and
noteworthy is that she's a biological
male who identifies as a woman yet
fights against males I think we took a
lot of time sometimes to point out the
inaccuracies or sometimes the
duplicitous of trans assets we try to
compete against the opposite sex we
think we're born with but to see a trans
Ally who's like no I'm going to compete
against my same sex because it's fair
and I acknowledge that I think it's dope
and so that's why I want to commend her
because she's doing what's right we
can't just take time to [ __ ] on the ones
we're doing it wrong we should also pick
up the ones that are doing it correctly
man big up to you if she's excelling and
she even said I don't want to take any
of the drugs to start the transition
physically because I know it'll affect
me physically and I won't be able to
compete at a high level so I went after
my career's done to go through that
process so she's doing that sacrifice to
go through that and I respect that
person because she's really about the
sport yes she loves it winning that's
really what you're about you understand
everything about the sport it's not
about winning it's about the sport
itself and competing at a best level and
out of fairness and people are
respecting it because they're making her
headline events not because she's a
trans person none of that because she's
skilled and she's good and it's fair and
nobody's complaining otherwise some
people are being bigoted towards her
because they just don't like the way she
looks that's a separate topic yeah but I
respect the fact that she's doing that I
love when she understands that what she
knows she knows that if she was in that
ring competing as females that she would
destroy the man it would be unfair just
dangerous actually so that's why I have
to commend her because she's not doing
what Fallon Fox did with you know mixed
martial arts where she broke a female
skull even though she was a biological
male know she's gonna get fair
competition and she's being respected
for it they didn't tell and in the case
of filing [ __ ] they didn't tell that it
was a possible man yeah they tell her
opponent yeah yeah but you know again
today I don't want to harp on this topic
too long exciting the day this affects
female sports
and the truth is I personally don't
watch female sports I don't take an
interest in it it doesn't but what I do
see something that to me is unjust it's
unfair and people are trying to let it
pass in the name of walk this and I'm
just like no this is dangerous and
that's why I discuss it stop but I do
think it's important that women are the
ones who lead this discussion because
your sports are the ones that are
threatened anything else you want to add
about I think she would have a field day
what's your bid but of course of course
no doubt no doubt no doubt
I feel they would sure but but man I
remember I was hanging out with a whole
bunch of dudes and they like just like
hi bro would you want a million dollars
or you got asked it locked in a room
with Mike Tyson and he can do whatever
he wants to you if I want a million
dollars
like would you take a million dollars to
be in that room with Michael Jackson
Michael Jackson either one's terrifying
[Laughter]
so would you take them being dogs to be
locked in the room with Mike Tyson for
an hour or would you just not take that
money be free for an hour yeah I'm good
I'm not that broke for an hour man I've
seen this man
primetime Mike I've seen Mike right now
giving advises to people I've seen mine
right now giving advice of people and
move super quicker than I will ever move
in my life ever I've seen Mike Tyson put
away people under 30 seconds you give
him an hour
you don't scare and now not even scary
that his strength it's also just hearing
that voice the darkness I couldn't you
know what's gonna happen priest I'm
gonna take you down I'm gonna take you
down yes I am like nothing nothing is
gonna be able to stop me and say what I
was like
this is a he said that that press
conference yes like now what Mike was
unhinged too though yes I'm super happy
for Mike Tyson is his transition yes
yeah so I'm good for him trans Mike is
nice but all this is a back so just I
wanted to give her a shout out because I
think sometimes especially this channel
were always dissecting things that are
illogical or unjust but it's also
important to have it bounce to that and
also understand that you know we're
human beings when we see something
that's good we do feel some type of way
we just don't always cover it and so
that's somebody I really wanted to
highlight because I'm like yo she's
killing it I gotta give her that she's
killing it yeah anyways leave your
comments below what do you think about
her and what she's doing in Thailand
right yeah it's telling you in Thailand
yeah so we wonder what you guys think
leave your comments below and yeah
that's about it for today
[Music]